someone wanted to know my opinion on
bone broth so let's talk about that you
know people eat a lot of muscle from the
animal but they don't consume the rest
of the animal they're eating a lot of
meat from chicken or beef lamb pork etc
and that problem with that is that the
muscle is very high in methionine which
is an amino acid bone broth will give
you glycine and a different profile of
amino acids so at least doing bone broth
you're getting another part of the
animal but I also recommend consuming
some of the organ meats as well livers
the easiest to consume you can get that
in a pate so us wellness meats has a
great product it's a liverwurst which
has heart and liver together it's a
great product you don't need to consume
much of it but at least you're getting
more of the whole animal and when you
can send me more bone broth you're
getting more glycine and that
potentially could help your sleep your
blood sugars and build up your
neurotransmitters bone broth also is
good to support your gut and joint
health ok it's really simple to make
this is how you do it you buy three
pounds of bones I like to get this from
the farmers market then you get a pot
that holds two gallons of fluid okay
you're gonna fill it up with water about
two inches from the top okay you're
gonna put the bones in there you're
gonna put two tablespoons of apple cider
vinegar in there and just let it sit for
30 minutes the the acid will help to
start breaking down the minerals from
the bone the goal is to extract the
minerals and the nutrients and the
collagen and the amino acids from that
bone okay and you have to cook it I also
add herbs spices vegetables sea salt in
there and then I bring it to a boil and
then bring it down to simmer for about
10 to 24 hours
the longer you go the more nutrients are
extracted let it cool down strain out
the material put in I put like to put it
in glass jars and then I will use that
in different soups or stews and for
convenience you can actually buy this
already done there's one company that I
really really like it's called kettle
and fire so one of the reasons I like
this company's we use grass-fed
pasture-raised organic products so it's
pretty good
this one is with lion's mane superfood
mushrooms here's one with tumeric ginger
they have did a lot of different flavors
coconut curry lime and of course the
ingredients are really really good
there's no sugar or anything like that
there's no fillers and here's one
broccoli cheddar soup so you can consume
these in soups or stews and they're very
keto friendly and on top of that they
will actually spend the time and cook
these bones for 24 hours because a lot
of times when you get broth it's only
for a very short period of time anyway
that's my opinion on bone broth thanks
for watching if you're liking this
content please subscribe now and I will
actually keep you updated on future
videos